some gold-plated chains would make a
nice retirement gift for a very very
good slave well this are you serious
well this was are you serious years ago
just right that I didn't write you say
that no I read it yes scribes the
Dostoyevsky metro station that it's
depressing murals as the mecca for
suicides not to be confused with the
mecca for suicide bombers which is Mecca
we need to be quick though because I
want to hear more so how how do you get
a hundred Jews into a mini one in the
driving seat ninety nine in the ashtray
all right well we'll start with that one
example and we won't borrow of them in
its size that you would dare to think
what I would think about that because
you have no knowledge no above that at
all how do you make a gay [ __ ] a woman
[ __ ] in her [ __ ]
I know I know I know don't think I don't
know because I know I know I know I know
guy walks into a bar
Joan Rivers's the bartender he sees a
sign over the bar that reads cheese
sandwich a dollar-fifty [ __ ] ten
dollars he cents the Joan Rivers are you
the one that gives the hand jobs Joan
says yes I am he says well watch your
heads [ __ ] I wanna cheese sandwich
my cousin nice to be really close and I
mean really close but then last thing's
giving me economy having sex with his
girlfriend and we haven't spoken since
I'm sure I'll get over it eventually
though you know I mean he's only 12 I'm
sorry I messed that up I mess it up it's
a new joke I'm sorry it makes me sound
like a pervert she was wearing makeup
you know what I mean like father sitting
at home just reading the newspaper his
little girl comes running in she's only
six hello darling hello daddy
you've been playing yeah in the park
yeah with your friends well until the
man came along till the man came along
yeah man came along and he asked my
friends to leave so it's just me and him
darling come over whatever happened none
of it was your fault okay darling none
of it was your fault but tell daddy
every detail what happened um
he took me behind a tree so no I could
see what you were doing I've got darling
and then what happened um he took my
dress off Oh God
what happened next one um he took his
thing out Oh God Donegan then what
happened nothing that was it Oh we'll
make something up
should I tell you I'm late one late
joining I think I can explain myself to
you knows a wee boy my granddad used to
take me up into the loft
I take throw in a chest
they hide up there he'd open up the
chest you know what wasn't it
a mere maid and he'd have me strip naked
as a b-boy and make love to that me I
made on the floor well he watched for
his sexual gratification
now usually uh when the old bastard was
dead I went back up into the loft I took
down the chest opened up do you know
what I found in there a dead monkey with
its legs soon together
[Applause]
you remind me of that monkey Johnny I
don't know what it is I know it's bad I
don't want her to somebody somewhere
there's something wrong with like I'll
say it the other day that you can figure
out how bad a person you are by how soon
after September 11th you masturbated
like how long you waited and for me it
was between the two buildings going down
this country why do we allow so many of
our innocent kids to be shot to death
why did we allow that as a country you
know why did well not us
God why does God we have no control over
the situation also all in God's hands
why does God allow so many of our
innocent kids to be shot to death and
you know they I mean I know he has
mysterious ways y'all but him what is he
thinking what are you thinking God
taking on I'm not questioning you cuz I
know you have your mysterious ways you
are I'm nipping in nono all wise but it
just seems like you're taking an awful
you what is the thinking behind it I
just
[Applause]
that's something that a lot of people
ask you know why is God allowing so many
of our innocent kids to be shot to death
and I have a possible answer and you're
not going to like it but maybe maybe
maybe God is allowing so many of our
kids to be shot to death so that they
can go to heaven where they then service
the ISIS terrorists and suicide bombers
as part of the 72 virgins are rewarded
with
[Applause]